Leute, gibt es eigentlich
das perfekte Datingprofil,
mit dem ihr alle,
die ihr kennenlernen wollt,
von euch überzeugt?
Den einen Hack,
mit dem sich jeder in euch verknallt?
Welche Fotos wirken?
Wann ist der perfekte Zeitpunkt,
um nach einem Date zu fragen?
Wie gut, dass es für alles
die Wissenschaft gibt.
Auch für Onlinedating.
Praktisch, dass ich jemanden kenne,
die sich so gut mit der Wissenschaft
des Datings auskennt,
dass sie ein Buch dazu geschrieben
hat: Pia von Psychologeek.
Zusammen gucken wir uns fünf Fakten
über Onlinedating an.
Ich sag mal so:
Leute, ich wünschte,
ich hätte das
alles etwas früher gewusst.
Kein Wunder, dass viele
nicht geschrieben haben.
Als kleines Gastgeschenk
verrät uns Pia am Ende
ihre liebste Opening Line.
Einen perfekten Satz,
mit dem ihr
ein lockeres Gespräch starten könnt.
Dann schließt alle anderen Tabs
und swipt uns nach rechts,
beziehungsweise lasst ein Abo da.
(Dynamische Musik)
Fangen wir direkt mit dem an,
was einen beim Online-Dating
mit am meisten belastet:
die Auswahl der Fotos.
Das ist die erste Hürde,
vor der wir stehen,
wenn wir unser Profil anlegen.
Schwarz-weiß oder farbig?
Alleine oder mit Freunden?
Verträumt oder ernst gucken?
In die Ferne oder in die Kamera?
Was mich dabei stresst:
Ich hab das Gefühl,
bei den Fotos geht's um alles.
Innerhalb von 100 Millisekunden,
das ist kürzer als ein Wimpernschlag,
entscheiden Menschen, ob sie jemanden
attraktiv finden, oder nicht.
Wenn das erste Bild nicht catcht,
war's das.
Ich hatte Fotos
in meinem Datingprofil,
auf denen ich mich selbst
attraktiv fand.
Ob die wirklich gut angekommen sind,
weiß ich nicht.
Und weiß die Wissenschaft da was?
Ich kenne den Profilbild-Struggle
nur zu gut.
Ich hatte auch superlange Fotos
von mir drin,
von denen ich dachte, dass ich darauf
irgendwie superhot und cool aussehe.
Eine Studie hat aber gezeigt,
dass es viel wichtiger ist,
dass Profilfotos auf
Datingplattformen authentisch wirken.
Je weniger gestellt und
damit echter Fotos nämlich wirken,
desto mehr Menschen
reagieren auf sie.
Ich dachte bisher:
Je besser, professioneller
und durchdachter die Fotos,
desto mehr Interesse.
Stimmt aber nicht.
Nehmt lieber
einen spontanen Schnappschuss
als ein
perfekt ausgeleuchtetes Selfie
oder ein Foto, auf dem ihr
offensichtlich posiert.
Warum ist das so?
Die Forscher:innen
erklären sich das so:
Wir checken Menschen, wenn wir sie
kennenlernen erst mal daraufhin ab,
ob wir ihnen vertrauen können.
Wenn man bei den Fotos das Gefühl
bekommt: "Hm, sieht fake aus!":
schwierig.
Übrigens: Pia hat mir erzählt,
dass sie ihr Profil
mit neuen Fotos bestückt hat,
nachdem sie die Studie gelesen hat.
Vorher hatte sie ein Foto drin,
wo sie gebräunt in Thailand
am Strand posiert.
Das hat sie getauscht gegen eines,
wo sie genüsslich
in ein großes Stück Pizza beißt.
Keine gute Idee ist es übrigens,
gar keine Fotos hochzuladen.
Oder Fotos, auf denen wir verpixelt
oder schlecht zu erkennen sind.
Untersuchungen haben ergeben,
dass das nicht mysteriös
oder geheimnisvoll wirkt,
sondern, dass das auf die Leute,
die die Profile sahen,
weniger interessant wirkte.
Apropos interessant wirken:
Dafür ist auch der Text wichtig,
hab ich von Pia gelernt.
Im Gegensatz zu Fotos hab ich mir
über den Text auf meinem Datingprofil
wenig Gedanken gemacht.
Profiltexte? Liest doch eh niemand!
Das dachte ich zumindest.
Nee, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Wissenschaftler:innen
haben nämlich herausgefunden,
dass der Profiltext
schon wichtig ist,
um die Attraktivität
einer Person einzuschätzen.
Auch hier: Vertrauen.
Kommt alles freundlich
oder vertrauenswürdig rüber,
finden wir das attraktiv.
Wie mache ich das,
möglichst vertrauensvoll zu wirken?
Am besten ist es, wenn der Text
zu euren Bildern passt.
Dann entsteht sozusagen
wie so ein rundes Bild von euch.
Um Onlinedating
weniger oberflächlich zu machen,
nutzt am besten die Chance,
um im Profiltext
etwas über euch zu erzählen.
Wer seid ihr?
Was ist euch wichtig?
Wonach seid ihr auf der Suche
auf den Datingapps?
Also, einfach mal mehr Infos
als nur aus welcher Stadt ihr kommt
oder vielleicht noch
wie groß ihr seid.
Außerdem achtet auch darauf,
dass keine Rechtschreibfehler
im Text sind.
Das kommt laut einer Studie
eher unattraktiv
und auch so "schlodderig" rüber.
Sachen wie: "Schreib mir, wenn du
dir die Herausforderung zutraust",
wirken tendenziell eher abschreckend.
An der Stelle möchte ich dazusagen:
Wir beziehen uns hier bei allem
auf Studienergebnisse.
Heißt natürlich nicht,
dass alles auf alle zutrifft,
und dass jemand falsch
oder komisch ist,
wenn er oder sie
sich davon unterscheidet.
Wenn es euch anturnt,
eine Person zu daten,
die sich selbst
als Herausforderung beschreibt:
Klar, go for it.
Aber weiter im Text,
also wortwörtlich.
Was genau sollte ich
laut Wissenschaft
am besten in mein Datingprofil
reinschreiben?
Sätze, die mysteriös wirken sollen,
so was wie:
"Finde doch heraus, wie ich so bin!",
kommen einer Studie zufolge
nicht gut an.
Sehr lange ausführliche Texte
aber auch nicht.
Und sexuelle Anspielungen
funktionieren nur bei Menschen gut,
die selbst eher an einer Affäre
als an einer festen Beziehung
interessiert sind.
Und wie steht's um Texte mit Emojis?
Top oder Flop?
Das kommt voll drauf an.
Wenn du an heterosexuellen Männern
interessiert bist, dann: ja, super.
Und auch queere Menschen
stehen auf Emojis.
Wer Emojis
allerdings nicht so besonders feiert,
das sind laut der Studie zufolge
heterosexuelle Frauen.
Ähm, ja, okay.
Gut zu wissen, I guess?
Manche wissenschaftlichen
Studienergebnisse
muss man kritisch sehen.
Das könnt ihr euch hier
bei meiner Kollegin Mai angucken.
Aber halten wir trotzdem mal fest:
Texte auf Datingapps
sind also wichtiger, als ich dachte.
Scheint doch nicht so oberflächlich
zu sein, die ganze Sache.
Fotos und Text: klar, wichtig.
Aber noch etwas
kann darüber entscheiden,
ob ihr nach links oder rechts
geswipt werdet.
Und zwar wie lange man schon
in der Datingapp rumhängt.
In Pias Buch habe ich gelesen:
Die Profile, die die App einem
als Erstes anzeigt, wenn man öffnet,
werden tendenziell
eher nach rechts gewischt.
Im Laufe des Swipens
sinkt die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass jemand ein Profil nach rechts
wischt um fast 30 Prozent.
Wie absurd ist das denn?
Da hat man so viele Möglichkeiten,
spannende Leute kennenzulernen
und das Interesse daran nimmt ab,
je länger man swipt?
Und dann noch um fast ein Drittel?
Wie kann man sich das erklären?
Diese Studie
fand ich auch sehr interessant.
Mein erster Gedanke war,
dass es bestimmt daran liegt,
dass Datingapps
die potenziell attraktiveren Fotos
als Erstes anzeigen,
damit wir sozusagen dranbleiben.
Aber das wurde
in der Studie kontrolliert.
Es scheint viel mehr so zu sein,
dass man im Laufe der Zeit
einfach unzufriedener
mit den angezeigten Bildern wird
so nach dem Motto:
"Jo, scheiße, hier ist
für mich wohl gar nichts zu holen."
Ei, ei. Ich weiß noch, dass ich schon
locker mal für 20 bis 30 Minuten
in einer Datingapp versacken konnte.
Aber stimmt schon. Mit der Zeit
war ich nicht mehr so aufmerksam,
habe schnell geswipt
und manchmal auch aus Versehen,
ohne mir alles
wirklich angeguckt zu haben.
Das ist natürlich ein kleiner Downer.
Wie lange andere
auf Datingapps rumhängen,
bis ihnen mein Profil angezeigt wird,
kann ich nicht beeinflussen.
Aber man kann dieses Wissen
für das eigene Swipen nutzen.
Wenn man nur zehn oder sogar nur fünf
statt 20 bis 30 Minuten swipt,
dann verlieren die Profile,
die einem angezeigt werden,
nicht so krass an Attraktivität.
Das bedeutet potenziell auch wieder:
mehr Chancen auf Treffer. Whuuuu!
Noch besser wird es,
je mehr Menschen davon wissen.
Spread the word, schickt dieses Video
allen Onlinedating-Fans.
Mehr Matches für alle. Nice!
Jetzt, wo wir uns
vor potenziellen Dates
kaum noch retten können,
kommt die nächste Frage:
Wie lange schreiben?
Wann ist es Zeit fürs erste Treffen
in Echt?
Ich meine, es gibt beim Dating viele
zum Teil auch etwas weirde Regeln,
die alle mit Zeit zu tun haben.
Kein Sex beim ersten Date,
aber beim dritten,
gerade wenn beim zweiten
geknutscht wurde.
Wenn dein Date sich nach vier Tagen
nicht gemeldet hat,
hat es kein Interesse.
Wenn die Person sich nach einer
Minute meldet, Finger weg. So was.
Gerade die Frage nach dem Wann
finde ich schwierig beim Daten.
Erst schreiben, dann treffen?
Wenn ja, viel oder wenig schreiben?
Wie viel Zeit lässt man
bis zum ersten Treffen vergehen?
Manche Menschen
haben in ihrem Profil stehen:
"Mag schreiben nicht, lass lieber
treffen und schauen, ob's passt."
Einfach mit einer unbekannten Person
treffen?
Ich schreibe lieber
ein paar Nachrichten,
um ein Gefühl zu bekommen,
mit wem ich es zu tun habe.
Hier geht's wieder um Vertrauen.
Mit einer Person,
die scary erscheint,
will ich
mich natürlich nicht treffen.
Wenn ich ein gutes Gefühl
und Lust auf ein Treffen hatte,
hab ich mich oft gefragt:
"Kann ich schon danach fragen?"
"Wirkt das zu pushy?"
Ich hatte aber auch schon,
wo keiner nach einem Treffen
gefragt hat
und es dann im Sande verlaufen ist.
Wissenschaft: send help!
Erste Studien zu dem Thema zeigen,
dass der 17. bis 23. Tag,
also knapp drei Wochen
nach der ersten Kontaktaufnahme,
ein guter Zeitpunkt ist,
um nach einem Date zu fragen.
Allzu lange sollte man damit
also nicht warten.
Aber man sollte
auch nicht zu schnell sein.
Warum hat mir Pia erklärt:
Wenn man beim ersten Date
miteinander schreibt,
hat das eine positive,
aber auch eine negative Seite.
Die positive ist, man ist
beim Schreiben häufig offener
als so im direkten Gespräch,
also so face to face.
Dadurch, dass man beim Schreiben
sich leichter emotional öffnen kann,
baut man schneller
eine emotionale Beziehung auf.
Das nennen die Forschenden
hyperpersönlich.
Aber es gibt auch die negative Seite.
Das Schreiben führt aber auch dazu,
dass man sich eine gewisse
Vorstellung von der Person
im Kopf zusammenspinnt.
Man stellt sich zum Beispiel
die Stimme der anderen Person vor,
und das kann am Ende
ganz schön schiefgehen,
schließlich kann die andere Person
ja gar nicht genau so sein,
wie man sich die vorgestellt hat.
So kommen die Wissenschaftler:innen
dann auf diese 17 bis 23 Tage.
Das ist der Zeitraum,
in dem man
schon diese hyperpersönliche
Beziehung aufbauen kann,
aber es noch nicht in utopische
Wunschvorstellungen kippt.
(Sie liest die Frage vor.)
Erzählt es in den Kommentaren.
Ich hatte oft Matches und dann hat
mir die Person nicht geschrieben.
Oder das Gespräch brach plötzlich ab,
Funkstille.
Das war immer ein Downer,
weil ich
natürlich schon gerne wollte,
dass Menschen mich cool finden
und mich treffen wollen.
An manchen Tagen war's mir egal,
ob jemand zurückschreibt.
An anderen konnten daraus
nagende Selbstzweifel werden.
Genau für solche Tage
ist mein nächster und letzter Fakt
so mindblowing.
Auf Tinder zum Beispiel ist
nur etwa die Hälfte der User:innen
zwischen 18 und 27 Jahren
überhaupt Single.
What?
Eine Studie hat gezeigt,
dass echt viele Nutzer:innen
nur für diesen Egoboost
auf Tinder und Co. unterwegs sind,
den sie etwa durch Matches bekommen.
So echtes Interesse am eigentlichen
Dating haben sie da selten.
Die wollen quasi
nur ihren Marktwert auschecken.
Andere sind auch einfach nur
aus Neugier oder Langeweile da.
Das ist echt gut zu wissen.
Wenn euch das nächste Mal jemand
nicht schreibt, fragt euch nicht:
"Woran liegt das wohl?"
Denkt euch vielleicht direkt:
"Aha! Die Person
gehört wohl zu den Menschen,
die gar nicht wegen Dates
bei Tinder sind!"
(Muntere Musik)
Bevor gleich noch der ultimative Tipp
von Pia kommt, meine Learnings:
Authentische Fotos
sind besser als gestellte.
Profiltexte sind wichtig.
Lieber nur ein paar Minuten swipen,
erhöht die Matchrate.
Nach knapp drei Wochen
fragt man am besten nach einem Date.
Wenn keine Antwort kommt,
liegt das vielleicht daran,
dass das Match
nicht an Dating interessiert ist,
sondern nur aus Neugier und für
den Ego-Push auf der Plattform ist.
(Sie macht Explosionslaute.)
Hätte ich gerne schon früher gewusst.
Damit's mit dem Chatten
dann auch läuft,
verrät Pia in ihrem Buch
einen simplen Trick,
um unverkrampft
ins Gespräch zu kommen:
Es ist immer gut
eine Frage zu stellen.
Ich frage zum Beispiel häufig,
an welchem Ort ein bestimmtes Foto
aufgenommen wurde
und was die Geschichte dazu ist.
Und was auch immer zieht:
Einfach mal nach dem Namen
vom Haustier fragen,
wenn etwa ein Hund
auf dem Foto zu sehen ist.
Was sind eure besten Datingtipps?
Schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Lasst Pia und mir gerne ein Like
und ein Abo da.
Ich hab übrigens Bumble, Tinder
und OkCupid mal verglichen.
Das Video findet ihr hier.
Noch mehr Datingtipps von unserem Pro
Psychologeek findet ihr hier.